[Music]
andy you seem like you've been in a bad
mood all week
well i'm still upset about what happened
this weekend
okay is this about mother's day is that
the problem yeah you're damn right it's
about mother's day
all right ladies and gentlemen i should
explain andy and i uh took our moms to
brunch last sunday we all got together
and took our moms and it it didn't quite
go the way we planned it
[Music]
well
here's your champagne mother
what a lovely brunch konzi
well
nothing but the best for you mother
happy mother's day oh cozy
um sir you can't come in here without a
jacket
you're lucky i'm wearing pants
hey conan oh hi andy uh where's your
mother
i left her in her home this place is
expensive and that chow hound can really
strap on the feed bag
hey
your mama's hot
uh just settle down andy okay uh you're
a camilf
a conan's mom i'd like to hey stop it
andy
you're drunk relax tight ass
she's not my mom which means i can do
this
oh my god
andy
oh
the back of my head
oh no not the plastic glass
[Applause]
sorry
[Music]
sorry for that drunken disturbance but
folks brunch is on me
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so i
[Applause]
we should have rehearsed this
well anyway see i don't know what you're
complaining about andy look that's not
what happened and you know it
well it was pretty close to what
happened no you were the one that was
rude to my mom remember
well
a little bit
[Music]
come on
get in there mom
where the hell is the maitre d conan i
don't like this plague oh quit squawking
the old crow
this is the hottest joint in town i've
got to be seen here i don't like seafood
i said be quiet
hi conan hello mrs o'brien uh mrs
o'brien i'd like you to be my mother
eleanor come on in mom
whoa
looks like someone forgot to bleach
stop it conan hey maybe after we eat we
can all hit the bleach
she's talking about andrew
he's implying that you have a thick dark
mustache mom
and he owes you an apology
you're right i'm very sorry sir
[Laughter]
that is it you're going out that window
no i'm not you are oh no
andy you have the car keys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he's a musician not an actor
anyway i'm sure glad they're dead
[Laughter]
oh i raced an a-hole
[Applause]
everyone
[Music]
[Applause]
well
whatever happened i think the point is
that both of our moms are men yes
very homely man